hi guys it's silverette again and yes
I'm starting a new series and in this
series I'm just going to build a
American town and get some nice downtown
area going on but also make some nice
houses and parks and this is basically
because I was watching loads of Sim City
videos and also playing Sim City myself
and not really being productive but it
was so much fun so I decided that I
would actually try and make a detailed
City or at least somewhat small town in
Roller Coaster Tycoon 3 now of course
many people have done this already but
I've rarely seen uh full grown cities
that are actually very detailed so
attention to Planters and very small
things and buildings Etc so I want to
give this a shot so that's why I'm doing
this right now so I wanted to just start
off with the Main Street this is going
to be the main road that's going to go
from like some some I don't know area
that's outside of town to the downtown
area at the end of this road so I'm just
going to add some nice little buildings
around this I felt like this would be
some kind of a company or a shop
something like this I just want to have
some commercial stuff going on uh on the
sides of this road so for the first
building I didn't really want to take a
risk so I started out with a building
shape which I kind of had in my head and
it really turned into something that I
really like so you're going to see that
at the end but I the the idea is
basically that I have that small over
hang as you can see by the pillars in
front of it and glass on the sides and
glass on the roof and it actually turned
out really great and this set of course
it's Moby steel I mean no not M steel
jungle holy I'm way I'm way too
used to saying that no it's it's mob's
glass house and Frameworks and it
actually turned out to be the most
useful set during the building of the
city so that's really awesome and this
is me trying to turn this into some sort
of a balcony but in hindsight I'm really
glad that that I didn't do it and kind
of just gave up on those weird fences
because this just worked a whole lot
better except for these columns they
don't work out either so this is loads
of experimentation and that's definitely
something that I need to do I can't
really get around that now it's it is
something that I kind of didn't want to
do especially with a let's play since I
do want everything to just be full
building and every and just no no well
wasting of time by exper exp menting
with different kinds of things but this
is really a um a town building a town
with sets that are meant for amusement
parks it really needs some
experimentation to kind of find out what
kind of pieces you need to use so that's
what I'm doing and as you can see on the
sides I I just kind of do the same as I
do in front and I'm not really going to
pay too much attention to the sides of
the buildings because they're all going
to be so close to each other and you're
not going to really see too much of it
but regardless of that I kind of wanted
to give this a little different color
just because it would look cooler I
guess I might also add windows at some
point to this but I don't think I've
done that yet so as you can see now the
building is really taking shape but I
did want to add that little glass thing
on the roof which is definitely going to
bring out the general shape of it and
those glass things on the sides so that
worked out really well and just one more
horizontal thing on top of it and at
this point that building is pretty much
finished and I really just wanted some
trees in front of it but the problem
that I had with this of course was I
wanted some subtle trees but not too
subtle not too small that you don't
really see them but also not too big
that you don't see the buildings anymore
and at this point I was messing around
with my own set for this building and
then eventually decided to just abandon
that because it didn't work out my set
is terrible so I decided to use Ralphies
instead simply because it has that more
white texture so and then also the brick
walls from the generic wall building set
which is really great for this this city
so it's it it was really awesome that
this came out just before I started
recording this so I could just pick up
that set and actually mess around with
it and I decided that it was it was
really great it's got loads of normal
brick walls in it that I'm using right
now but also other other fun stuff so
definitely using that and as you can see
this is a um somewhat of a town hall
building I don't exactly know what it is
but it's that neoc classic kind of
American typical town hall/ perhaps even
school I don't really know it's not
really that much of an important
building I I to be honest I really don't
have a clue I'm just building buildings
for the fun of it and if I think uh a
certain type of building would look cool
somewhere I'm just going to build it
regardless of whether it should serve a
certain function or not and I really
really like the combination of white
with those brick walls so I'm definitely
going to use that more in this town
and yeah here's the bell tower which I
actually had some problems with since I
needed a roof for that thing but I just
couldn't find any roof set so that's
really uh somewhat of a problem and I
think yeah I'm actually kind of looking
for some good spires over here too but
none of the spes were actually good then
of course I'm adding some American flags
on the sides because it's America and we
always need flags on American buildings
I don't know that's why I I think that's
the European cliche or something like I
tend to think that Americans like to
hang American flags outside all of their
buildings but of course that's
but it's still somewhat funny to add it
like it it seems like an important
building now and this is why I start
building on a building that I'm not
going to finish in this episode but in
the next one and yeah it's somewhat more
modern than the other ones more concrete
and um glass stuff and again those nice
little pillars but yeah as you can see
the town is shaping up pretty nicely so
in the next episode I'm going to finish
that building so till then